hello and welcome to this video yeah
playing Thomas Tallis and we'll see i'm
going to go for the Semites laughs just
for the heck of it I really have no idea
but let's see what happens I am
recognized and I never played this on
video much I could go to the board
Winnick but ok let's do this main line
here which neglects one of the one of my
one of my rules never play b5 and g5 in
the same in the same game because it
yeah mix a position look like a bunch of
holes ok go into e1 that's a funky move
if you want to go does he want to do
here d 5 maybe ok I think maybe getting
this Bishop is an idea the good thing of
all blacks position is I'm goth God upon
and it's it's better to have one and
being 114 down now chest wisdom 101 yeah
of course he takes with the f porn so
that he opens up the f file that gives
some yeah Queen f2 that's what I'm
trying to say make some sense ok nitey
for is coming hmm
okay what can you do now i can t key
five here I'm just very uncertain if it
is any good I can still check it still
pretty awkward
hmm
yeah this is the kind of situation that
I always feel I have got problems with
its kind of completely messy it might be
okay but it's extremely difficult to
tell if I'm castling long here 96 check
king be 89 f 7 it doesn't look good but
I'm absolutely not sure if I can take
only 5 95 96 king is seven-night b7
Knight f3 hmm am I losing this position
I I don't see it I really don't okay
he has to give the check now okay 95
Bishop b5 look at seven King Dick's I i
didn't i didn't see how i'm losing here
which is probably my own Mountain
problem not be seven I take on g4 and
this night is trapped on b7 I think okay
this is this and that might lose that
mean what I'm not stating anything else
but ok I can take be seven and then move
the king I mean I will have an exchange
up I can also take you for first which
is very likely better check
check okay King king is not comfortable
but I dont still don't see how I do is
here 25 I mean black Bishop g4 and 25
this kind of thing but I can go can go
to be six it's not such a huge deal
check
okay I don't ok now i cannot take
because h eight is hanging huh that's a
bit uncomfortable and c5 i can actually
place you five in this position it's not
okay can take on b7 first okay and I
have to go back here I guess
25 king CA to check
and this kind of thing is why I don't
play this line normally because you
always get this kind of weird positions
where you are material up and they kind
of hunt your king it's very often
winning if you if you see it as a kind
of mathematical exercise but it's not so
easy to prove especially not if you have
a blitz situation here
I'm not sure about this but I have to
get going if I get the King to be seven
it should be reasonably safe
now exchange in two or three pawns up so
it's just avoiding the maid
and you know I will take on g4 check
very soon
yeah one minute left should be enough
there should be two I expect the strands
root deewana with mate and activates
this piece you cannot go h3 here Kim Ji
Won so it's not so easy to find a movie
even okay check white resign so i
weathered this storm yeah it's a
mentally tough this is this line I think
that I'm ethically black should be ok
but yeah just very tough to play um I
cannot really tell you anything about
them this is the the theoretical
evaluation here Queenie one however I
have a hard time that this should be
good I think they normally play the
Queen to see too but there are various
ways of doing this age for first I mean
before castling with I don't know oh
this is looked normal to me that same
right I tried grabbing grabbing the
Bishop Bishop is always a very dangerous
piece in this situation because most of
my weaknesses here are dark squared
weaknesses so I'd like to get get rid of
its g3 bishop yeah taking with this
opens up the F file at least and maybe I
should just play Bishop e7 now instead
of Bishop g7 this e 594 was certainly
tricky and I'm absolutely unsure if I
can take only five now that might just
lose it does lose okay the computer at
sup + 5 okay so it doesn't work at all
check and now 95 this should be five
rookie 7 I took on the six huh there
must be a complete win o Queen before
check I told
missed queen before that's made ah I
thought you missed it as well oh I
totally did not see this move oh my
goodness ah that's painful it's it's
it's a checkmate it's a mate check
checkmate yeah I had this nagging
feeling a test open up Oh God yeah okay
no no I'm winning check he has some well
this is what what he did yet some some
sweet link chances but there's some no
real compensation here jennylyn if you
run into the mate wow I was immensely
lucky yeah this is the thing in this
kind of line I always hate to have my
king expose this is just that be 555 you
never know where to go with that with
the king I probably should castle here
then what player should be selling it
that might be better if he now goes for
this I can even think of castling long I
Queen B 6 and long it's still very murky
but i doubt that white has enough for
the pawn and down with that but um it's
a ella said it's very very murky
anything can happen it was a very lucky
game okay thanks for watching